a video so
of all the panelists pinned up
[Music]
and let me
let me start by
introducing the panelists so we have a
great panel um
several of whom you you've seen many
times on this
before so they need little introduction
scott aronson um i think you all know um
he's of course you know the most
relevant thing to this lecture is that
he's um
he's he of course uh introduced the
notion of shadow tomography and
which sort of got some of this work
going he recently received the acm prize
in computing but
you know there's much more to say but
i'll move on
uh there's doritharan who again needs no
introduction here she
she introduced many um
many of the important uh you know
results right from the beginning of the
field fault tolerance and
universality of adiabatic computation
but again for this particular
colloquium the most relevant things are
that she's you know she was one of the
first people thinking about um
how to verify quantum computations as
well as you know introducing these these
ideas about interactive experiments uh
quantum experiments um
dorito of course is now
also uh founded a company called credma
which which deals with uh
with um
benchmarking
[Music]
quantum benchmarking and maybe even
interactive experiments we don't know
uh
we also have ignacio sirat who
who of course
is a
is a
condensed matter theorist
um who's who um
who has introduced most of the many of
the
early ideas about how to actually
translate
um
you know theoretical ideas into actual
uh you know practical um
uh experimental setups you know so how
to create quantum computers in practice
um he's the winner of the wolf prize and
the max blank medal among among other
things
and then it's great to also have uh
ilat hazan who is
from princeton um
he's he's um he's uh he's also the
co-founder and the director of the
of google ai at princeton
uh
elad is um
is the
is the co-inventor of the ada grad
algorithm for deep learning
and um he's also worked extensively on
convex programming and for those of you
who've
uh you know you you probably
you know if you've seen ip equal to p
space you you probably know about the
very famous uh
hassan kali uh result
so um
so maybe we can can we start with uh
with um you know your reactions to the
talk and your comments about it and
in any order maybe um
who would like to go first uh
scott do you want to start since you
well yeah no i i really enjoyed this
talk um
you know i mean i've been amazed by what
people have done over the last couple of
years with you know this framework of
classical shadows and applying it to
various physics problems you know i feel
like i've you know contributed almost
nothing to the subject of shadow
tomography at this point you know other
than you know uh uh whatever i mean i i
didn't i i i i i i did write the first
paper about it but i didn't even give it
its name uh steve flamia uh who i see is
here is the one who suggested this uh
this cool name of shadows um
uh but you know so so there were there
were two kind of uh very different uh uh
directions that were that were discussed
today uh the first one was was sort of
not uh complexity at all it was sort of
about a question that is uh orthogonal
to you know what we usually worry about
in uh um
in
in in quantum computing it was about
sort of just what
what aspects of the system are are
learnable at all right or you know which
aspects of the world are are are uh sort
of intrinsically hidden from us right i
know this is this is not at all a new
question i mean i was just saying in the
chat window right this is a question
that in some sense goes back hundreds of
years in physics right and you know a
lot of the progress in physics was
precisely to realize sort of which
aspects of our equations actually
correspond to something that's
observable and which ones are are are
are are not observable or are just you
know um um aspects of the the
coordinates that we chose or whatever um
and uh you know so so uh you know um
physicists don't you know stay up at
night worrying that you know because of
gage
transformations that you know that
there's some problem with the scientific
enterprise you know they just say that
well the things that we can't measure
are are
if they really cannot be measured uh uh
in principle then they are unphysical
you know and uh if they can't be
measured but just by this set of of of
allowed operations uh but a different
set you know uh would allow us to
measure them well then that's just the
limitation of that set of operations um
you know but i mean you know we could
give another example right they suppose
that last night ever you know someone
came and replaced every complex number
by its conjugate right how would we know
well you know we wouldn't know right you
know that's okay but uh um
you know you can you know you could
construct an example based on that of
two uh world models that were uh
um you know in the sense of this work
that were indistinguishable for uh from
one another even though they're they're
formally different okay now uh the the
second part of the talk uh was about
these uh separations uh uh uh like uh
learning tasks that a a quantum learner
could do with only you know of one
axises or samples or whatever even
though a classical learner would
probably need an exponential number of
samples you know building on earlier
work and
you know
including some very recent work in the
same direction
and um
so so i i i like these kind of results i
did want uh um
to get clarification about something
which is you know when when you talk
about quantum versus classical learners
right it sounds a lot like what you know
back in the in the olden days uh you
know we used to call just uh like you
know uh um coherent measurements or you
know entangling measurements versus
unentangled measurements right like in
the study of the hidden subgroup problem
right people became very familiar with
the fact that well okay if i have to
measure each coset state separately i
might need many many more samples than
if i can do you know an entangled
measurement on all of them together
right so it sounds like you know
it sounds just kind of kind of like a
new
terminology for that you know in which
case it's you know it it's it's it's
very good to know you know not not not
not surprising i would say that these
separations uh should exist but maybe
i'm missing something
ah i see so i guess in
so in this previous
settings you're saying about
having these copies and people can do
like povn measurements on each copy
and potentially adaptively
changing yeah it's only possible to
consider it i see i see
yeah in terms of that
i think
for learning about states
that does sound like a very similar
setting um as here but um i guess here
the purpose
is to understand what are some slightly
more practical
situation that people would actually
care about um i'm not
entirely sure about um the practicality
about these costa
problems but i do think that these like
predicting properties and so on could
potentially be more useful in real world
such situations so i guess that's also
one of the
main aim is to um
understand if it's possible and we use
the different words i mean actually in
our paper there have been a lot of words
for it like i think in dorwan's paper
it's called incoherent qualm versus
coherence in some of our more recent
work we're calling them algorithm
without classical memory versus
algorithm with classical memory with
quantum memory uh and without quantum
memory so there is quite a few of words
um but i guess that are those aren't
just words but deep in the heart it's
really about a similar thing but i also
do feel like uh there's this other
aspect which is like when it's a quantum
process rather than just states i think
in states it's much clearer and people
can have studied it like in this hidden
states um before these quantum processes
um i think there's it has not been
formally
like properly defined how to separate
between them so
and in
dorit's older work i think she
considered it
um also slightly different from how we
consider it later which is a more
generalized version
in certain situations okay it's probably
the rich
you have things to say
i just want to remark i think scott
maybe maybe i'm not aware of that but um
i think that that
previous works didn't consider adaptive
situations and this makes the proofs
much much more complicated like
ruling out
independent samples
incoherent independent samples
is much easier than than ruling out what
you can do adaptively
oh i agree with that no if you're
talking about the hidden subgroup
problem you know i completely believe
that the work you know did not handle
the adaptive case i mean i know that in
my paper on shadow tomography and then
you know maya and guy rothbomb's uh
later paper on
you know general measurement and
differential privacy we we explicitly
raised this question right we asked
whether you know adaptive measurements
you know uh uh uh will will help whether
they'll you know they'll let you do as
well as you could have done with uh an
entangling measurement or i guess with a
a quantum memory or or a qualm you're
calling it i don't know you know i might
have some qualms about that
[Laughter]
about that acronym but uh but but uh you
know but but we we we
we we asked this question and and i'm
very happy that that this question now
now seems to have an answer that yes
with you know coherent measurements you
can do better than you can do with
adaptive measurements
yeah thanks a lot dory for clarification
i i for some reason i thought scott
meant that
even for adaptive scenario people
already solve it but okay that's good to
know
did you think you know
we were aware of it as a thing that one
should do but
yeah
so scott did you have more
whose turn is now so dory please please
okay
um so okay so robert thanks a lot for
the really beautiful talk um i wanted to
i wanted to say a few things first of
all about for me this is a fascinating
subject um
umesh mentioned earlier uh interactive
experiments i think all interac all
experiments are interactive
um the thing that's really exciting in
in your work and in previous works um
also what we were interested in in our
work with uh with jordan kotler and
charlene she is is uh is making this
structured making really that this is
sort of for me a start of of a theory of
how
physicists interact with nature in a
structured way much like
um interactive proofs do
um and the whole the whole process of
you know any experiment even
you can't really isolate one experiment
from the next experiment so a single
experiment can be non-interactive but in
fact the whole process of a physicist
with nature is an interactive process
and making this structured in and
and
uh you know uh providing a framework to
study this i think this is really an
important step inside in in you know and
understanding the scientific method um
so so to me this is really really
interesting um
uh and i wanted to to also say that uh
you mentioned uh the experiment uh on
sycamore um
and i think i think this is still
there's still this open question of the
noise of of handling noise
in the system right i mean this is not
uh we still don't know if uh if these
quantum advantages can be
uh seen even in the presence of noise
uh the exponential advantages is that
true that i mean this is this is also
true right so actually and and in the
first part i talked about like learning
these noisy systems and so on so in that
in that paper actually it hasn't been
put out yet it'd probably still take a
long time a while
since we're reading out but basically we
have a proof showing that
um like the task we consider like this
learning physical states task
when
the
like this quan like this quantum agent
procedure when there's noise in this
confirmation
um
you can show that the advantage would
still be there but now it would be a
polynomial advantage rather than an
exponential advantage
and the exponent of the polynomial will
actually increases as the noise
decreases and
it can increase indefinitely so
basically approaching exponential more
and more so as the noise becomes smaller
and smaller and smaller um the
polynomial advantage becomes bigger so
like for example here are some concrete
numbers if there's like one percent of
error in a two qubit operation then one
could show that the advantage would
actually be something like nc will be
which is the number of experiments
required by classical asian will be
equal to unq which is the number of
experiments required by quantum agent to
the power of 18 which is a huge
polynomial advantage in that kind of
regard so so yeah so
in the noise say noisy setting how to
achieve exponential advantage still not
clear to me but at least we can have
this like very large polynomial
advantage and that's actually what's
happening in the sycamore experiment um
we're seeing here
okay so let me maybe i if it's possible
i could show it again but in this part
of the graph
where we're seeing the separation
between this exponential and this seems
to be much flatter so note that this is
a log scale this seems to be much
flatter um but i think this is still
something that's kind of um
exponential in system size but just with
a much much
flatter kind of uh
scaling so so so the resulting would be
like a polynomial advantage rather than
an exponential advantage but it's still
a very large advantage as one could sort
of extrapolate here and so on so
yeah thanks um i i want to say that i
think conceptually the answer to this
question is known we do know that in
fault tolerant i mean if if somehow the
physical system that you're trying to
study is fault tolerance then
then it is known that there would be an
exponential advantage but but just
coming up with uh a real scenario uh
would be very interesting i think i
think also there is this interesting
difference i mean there's sort of two
aspects learn when you you talk about
learning from the point of view of
learning theory
this this focuses on the number number
of experiments and number of samples
and there's also the
a different aspect which is the actual
complexity of the experiment
and it's very easy to confuse between
them um they're they're different and uh
and i think uh both both questions are
very very interesting
um
right so for my talk most of the time i
focus on this uh sample complexity a
number of experiments um but at least
for the experiment like the actual
physical experiments we do they have to
be like computationally efficient and
then they are computationally efficient
but yeah but some yeah but most of the
time i focus on that and there could be
some difference for example when the
number of experiments doesn't have an
exponential separation it's still
possible that the computation time has
an exponential separation or something
like that
so that's a
great comment
thanks terry
um
ignacio
[Music]
okay well
so let me start just thanking for this
uh great talk it's really very clear i
think um
and uh
well i have several comments so first i
wanted to say that i'm the only
physicist here but i think that dory is
also pcc so or at least studied physics
at some point
anyway so my i mean i'm coming this from
a different direction so probably you
might ask my questions and my comments
are going different direction
so a very general comment so i think
that uh physicists like me are getting
very excited about all these results
coming from computer scientists
about physics and so
really i mean for some years we had many
uh results in computer science about
computer science about
algorithms quantum algorithms ways of
solving some problems uh faster but now
we see that we can
learn a lot from from them from their
methods and i mean dory just mentioned
these interactive proofs and the way
that we interact with experiments and
also very similar when you present it
here and all the works that you and john
and all the people have done in the past
so try to to know that
now uh in particular um i would say that
uh from the point of view of many body
physics that's the part that i'm
interested in uh i mean i see uh i'm
very clear
the uh things to learn from uh these
shadow
methods in general and in particular i
think that they would be very powerful
in company in combination with
some other classical
methods for simulation in which you just
get the results from classical computers
and you can predict things beyond what
you can do i mean with these other
methods and also with quantum
simulations right now there is in the
physics community there is a lot of
interest now we're using
analog or quantum miss computers to
solve problems that we can assault in
classical computers and all the methods
that you're talking about i think that
they will be very useful and they are
already useful in that context so they
will go
so typically uh we are used in in our
field to i mean have
some i mean there is short algorithm
there is glorious algorithm and then
somebody takes an experiment with three
ions
this does experiment and publishes a
super science paper then with four
qubits and
another nature paper wonderful these are
demonstrations that do the force but
don't really don't have any implications
for our uh knowledge because they
wouldn't learn so much about that but i
think that now we are approaching the
the the situation in which we can learn
now really things with from the
experiments if you just take the methods
that you mentioned
now from the talk maybe some some
comments and some some questions and uh
so the comment is that
so the
two parts of the talk so first about
learnable uh
learnability about systems so i'm i'm
not so sure how to find direct
applications these two at least the
things that i have in mind but i guess
learning what is unlearnable would tell
us so how to improve our experiments to
make them learnable so i guess that
that's one of the messages that i'm
really taking from here so that scott
says that if it's not learnable then why
should we care that maybe we can do make
it learnable just by pushing a little
bit our hardware our methods
now regarding the second part of your uh
talk let me tell you some something that
would be very intriguing and uh i'm very
interested in the context of analog
quantum simulator so that people have
now
either atoms or ions superconducting and
then they can uh just engineer
interaction between the keywords in such
way that they represent
some model that you would like to solve
and you cannot talk with a classical
computer this happens in condensed
metaphysics in chemistry in
in higher knee physics
and so i'm
i'm wondering how this applies now to a
real problem so in the sense that at the
end i mean i want to solve let's say
a lattice qcd for qcd for young meal
theory or something i give you a
hamiltonian and i tell you and that's
something that i cannot answer with a
classical computer now i give it to you
i let it interact with that quantum so
you cannot only prepare a state but you
can also now measure and depending on
the measure do something and so how what
what can i learn so what i will be able
to solve with that
and of course taking into account that
these systems and these models are not
perfect so there was also race in some
previous uh questions so i like to put
everything together like many of the
questions that we are asking today to
see some practical problem that i think
that is urgent to solve in physics
and how now with the experiments but the
methods that you're presenting or dorito
or scot and so on then it can help to
solve these methods or you see it at the
moment more like a i mean like some kind
of fundamental study in which i mean
you're is
trying to learn about more but i mean
the experiments are not at that position
and cannot
i mean there's not yet so much
to do let's say to to learn in physics
from what you're saying so my question
is then that's a
can you envision now some particular
scenario let me 100 cubits in a lattice
in which i can have an error brigade or
something forever in my hamiltonian
and then i would be able to do things
that i cannot do with a classical
computer
yeah i think that's a that's a that's
that's the question i think that's the
question that everyone in our field
we're trying to answer um for the talk i
think it's more as you said um at the
moment it's more like some
fundamental results that
could potentially build us towards
answering that question so like we
discuss all about these advantages but
how could this advantage be useful when
would we want to predict these kind of
properties
and
understanding this connection i think
it's a very important future work um
and to realize it in
in nature like
yeah like we we know that there are
situations where one could use this
classical shadow method but of course
using classical shadow method you can
still
combine it with quantum simulators like
analog quantum simulators and
and
do things with that so
um
but yeah maybe maybe maybe a bit more
specific so imagine that i have uh an
experiment and i would like to solve
some
make some predictions about let's say
the dynamics or the ground state or
something
of a hamiltonian that i cannot build
with my system so i mean i i have for
example atoms and the atoms have two
body interactions so they have microneed
and have like two lockers are two local
but the hamiltonian that i want to solve
is forward
and of course we can use perturbation
gadgets and so on like that but i mean
this perturbation gadget will make the
noise much bigger because i have to work
in perturbations here so is there
uh something that i mean there is is
there a procedure in such a way that uh
i mean your method could help these
methods in general could help me to not
to have to building in these gadgets but
rather with what i have to to learn and
then to use them to make predictions
that have some
yeah so i guess that that would be
closer to sort of my review on what john
prescott talked about where we consider
like these classical machine learning
combining classical shadows for
predicting ground states or
um
these kind of quantum media body
problems so so yeah i think that's
indeed what we envisioned um
the going forward on that part of the
line actually i've actually covered
quite a few different lines that could
be branched out i think this is
particularly closer to to that in the
sense that i guess in in this case
you're probably not going to have a
quantum computer since you're just
trying to build a quantum system so
you're probably not going to have a
quantum computer but only have classical
computer but you can do some kind of
quantum measurements on your system in
order to understand it then
yeah i think it's uh it's closer to that
line we do have some results on
on that front in the sense that um we
can have we can learn from certain
physical system that people could build
and then we can predict properties about
systems that's never been created in the
physical lab so some of your examples
that you said i think potentially fits
into it
however we do know that in our proof at
least at the moment what we consider is
more of like a statistical generation
since that we can sample randomly in the
space and then generalize but not in the
sense that we only sample partially like
in a small part of the space and then we
wanted to generalize to something that's
very different um
i think
currently i'm not entirely sure maybe
hilar would have some comments on it
about whether it's possible to have this
kind of more stronger form of generation
like you only learn from the subset and
then you wanted to predict for a bigger
subset what kind of guarantee could we
have and so on i think that's still a
little bit unclear at the moment even in
just the machine learning field in
general
but yeah but i think that line of work
could potentially one day be useful for
answering this question
i want to just say that i think that the
ignacio question is is basically a
question about a quantum algorithm right
i mean we're actually looking you have a
problem
um in mind and we're looking for a
quantum algorithm which involves
you know physical systems that we're
sampling or that we're probing and you
know the design of quantum algorithms is
a very very complicated task we don't
have a general method i mean this is
basically the beginning of a theory of
of quantum algorithms for you know
quantum protocols for learning physical
systems or measurements uh but we don't
have a general recipe for that
but there is so many maybe if i so
i agree with that but i was putting on
top of that the fact that we don't have
uh you have some restrictions also from
the physics side and so that we are not
able just to build any two qubit gates
anything that you want perfectly and so
there are things that we can do well
things that cannot be done well and
whether it but already at this level
there's something that you can help
that's that
that goes in that direction yeah yeah
right i mean so the sycamores
example is such an example the the
experiment that robert was talking about
is as an example in a very restricted
setting
but yeah that would that's a
i would basically like to understand the
details of your question to understand
the algorithmic question more precise
okay well thanks ignacio so elath has
been waiting very patiently so it would
be great to hear
your perspective from the viewpoint of
classical machine learning or you know
from from from your viewpoint about uh
sure can you hear me
yeah
yeah okay good well
thanks so much for inviting me really a
pleasure to be here and
um i hope i can say something
interesting the little i know
about quantum me i learned from dorit
who was teaching me in undergrad
and then i also happened to be a friend
of
with
scots
a little bit but i know it's not like
i'm an expert on the subject i hope i
can say something from the lens of
machine learning
and
like similar to what ignacio said i'm
excited by the relationship between the
two fields
so quantum tomography was or shadow
tomography
was a very nice connection between
learning and
um and quantum theory
and it gave back to learning also
because there are all these special
regularizations that you can look at and
in the complex plane and so on to help
classical learning as well but of course
also gives back to learning theory
um
so in in that light i want to say um a
little bit about the relationship that i
kind of reminded me
in the two parts of your talk so the
first part
talked about
tomography or learning
and and this pertains to some kind of
supervised learning or i would say
active learning because you're kind of
trying to actively design the queries to
the
the state under and in further state
from that
and
and this reminds me so i'm just talking
about it reminds me of a field called
the
experiment design i mean i myself have
studied this before but only from the
perspective of what scott taught me
which is basically unconstrained
um activations i imagine this might
relate to what ignacio is saying in the
physical world are various constraints
you cannot query whatever you want
of the of the quantum state
and this amounts to
physical constraints that you can in
interest in the classical world poses a
geometric constraint on the set that
you're occurring from
um this has been very well studied in
statistics it's called optimal design of
experiments
and there is a very interesting set of
math
that because you can see that there is a
relationship to geometry right a strong
relationship to convex geometry
what kind of points can you query and
let's say you have a budget you're only
allowed to pick 10 points
what's the optimal 10 points you can
query in the space that will give you
the max amount of information
and there are various interesting
solutions very interesting but from a
mathematical point of view in the
classical world
and i would be very interested to see
what happens in the quantum world
you asked robert
how it pertains to generalization i
guess maybe this was more the second
part of the
so maybe i'll talk about part two
so part two
was a bit more ambitious and here you
have not only
queries but they also affect the system
and kind of propagates
right you have in quantum world i never
understood that perfectly but you when
you query you also affect the state and
and so on so there is an effect of
of the action on the system
and in machine learning
i should say in quantum the learning
literature that i'm familiar with is
restricted to supervised learning and
active learning
but um we don't as humans we don't only
learn from observation from experiment
we learn from
um action taking action and then
observing this is called reinforcement
turning or control
control is very similar by the way to
what you presented along the mark in a
minute we learn from imitation
apprenticeship teaching teachers
will learn
in my opinion the unsolved mystery so
far as deduction so
right so serious relativity is not from
observation it's from only from
deduction of
what we know from other
observations or actions in the past so
there are many mechanisms for learning
and
i feel that at least i haven't seen much
literature in the quantum world about
it's very interesting to see what the
quantum agent can do with these other
types of
learning mechanisms
most related to what you discussed
is that of um learning and dynamical
systems because you have
the effect of influencing the system
that you touch upon
and
i don't know how much this audience is
familiar with the linear dynamical
system that's the simplest possible
version of reinforcement learning
where you take an action and that action
affects the system and you get to see an
observation and so forth so you not only
measure but you directly affect the
state of the world
by in the simplest possible way this is
linear but could be of course different
form of dynamics
um
and i would be very interested to see
there is some very deep mathematics
developed in the control theory world
it goes back decades in the you know
centuries very deep math about uh
how to study and and
identify is actually very related to a
system identification
um and
i think there is a lot of room for a lot
of potential from the techniques that
you discussed
and how they can be extended to that
world
of
linear learning and linear dynamical
system and system identification
um
great time
thanks a lot
um um
any any response robert to all the
comments i guess you've already been
saying stuff but um
yeah so so in particular for the last
comment i think these are
these are yeah these are very nice
comments and um
like for example i i actually never
haven't
dived deeply into these
classical theory on
experimental design it does felt like
what ignacio have talked about and this
field and potentially some of the
results that i've worked on might be
combined in some organic or interesting
way that could potentially lead to some
interesting results um
so yeah i would also look forward
and i'll probably spend some time
looking deeper into these kind of
literature
so thank you so much
sorry just um i i wanted to come back to
something so dureth i didn't quite
understand your idea your comments about
why what ignacio was saying was was
related to algorithm design or that it
boiled down to algorithm design so
could you
or did i misunderstand
um
no i mean so
so basically
can you hear me i'm not new to that
um
uh what i meant is that uh essentially
if if you don't only care about uh query
complexity but you care about the
complexity of the of the experiment
um
meaning uh the gate complexity plus
query complexity
um
then then what happens is that uh you
have to somehow
uh create a protocol of interaction with
the physical system
um that in a sense is a quantum
algorithm
which makes queries but also has has to
has to somehow massage the information
and and it's basically a quantum
algorithm
uh with which is more complicated than a
general quantum algorithm and
and i think that uh quantum algorithmic
ideas should enter the picture here and
as far as i understand we have really
just touched the the tip of the iceberg
from that point of view
um and you know uh designing experiments
with with quantum advantage when you use
coherent uh the quantum tricks that have
been used are very very rudimentary um
and and and also i think they're very
very limited so far
to specific cases and
and uh and for each for each particular
problem like ignacious problem is
is a specific in problem one one will
probably have to design
a new quantum algorithm
a meaning a new quantum algorithmic
measurement as we call it or a new
quantum protocol for a measurement
right so if i say something yeah
so uh so sometimes uh i guess that the
question that physicists can be
written in terms of hypothesis testing
so you have an hypothesis and you want
to know whether it's yes or not so you
have some
phase of matter
conducting nor superconducting and so
now you have a machine there and it is
not perfect that you know something but
you don't know anything like robert was
explaining so i mean the measurements
are not exactly like they are
you would like to see optimization so
how you can say yes no with the
maximum probability of guessing right
and then because then you have to
trickle and then that again is a kind of
optimization problem and then i guess
this optimization probably you formulate
it properly then you will have a set of
instructions quantum classical and
everything that you will have to give in
order to do that and you see as you know
is that i guess that you can formulate
it in that in that form however it's a
very difficult problem and in general i
don't know where to start basically so
the question is whether we can make a
systematic ways in which to approach
those solutions in order to get
answers because this is happening and
will happen more and more in the future
that we have these equipments and we
want to answer some questions but we
don't know if you were answering the
question or not or if it's optimal it's
and and things like that so i see that
from that point of view it's very useful
what you're i mean what you're
discussing here and the
work that you did in the past for all
three of you
yeah um
sorry robert just going going back to
this notion of um these entangled
measurements right that one has to do in
order to
so is
do you have a sense of well um
[Music]
you know what would making entangled
measurements that give you something
useful in practice you know
do you do you expect that to impose a a
major cost in terms of you know
how hard it is to
do those you know
create those highly entangled
measurements or
you know in terms of
the resources required or the resources
in terms of fidelity etc right
right right yeah so um
i really mentioned a few things like for
example in the experiments that we
implement on sikhomar processor that's
actually only a constant damps quantum
circuit so you have to copy and then you
just apply a constant dab quantum
circuit on top of it and then you can do
it so for that the fidelity requirements
and like i said is very low and even if
you have like five percent an error for
each two cubic gate you can already get
a huge polynomial advantage that could
be already be seen and that's why we are
seeing in
our experiments because like for example
in sigma processor their measurement
fatality is not very high whenever you
do a measurement on one qubit there
might be a roughly like three to five
percent of error that could happen um
but even in terms of that we could still
already see this kind of advantage so
for the situation that we consider like
for example predicting absolute value of
like poly observables and things like
that it's possible to realize it but
then the question is are they useful for
anything um so
i think you'll be most useful when the
situation is more like you wanted to
predict um a more general set of
observables and so on um however for
those kind of
problems like if you just have an
arbitrary general observable i think in
one of scott's previous work it's
already been shown that
it's highly
unlikely that one could actually predict
all of them very efficiently on quantum
computer there are some limitations to
that
with connection to complexity theory um
however it just seems possible that
um
um i would imagine situations where you
have
certain
uh more complicated many-body system um
maybe some material or certain certain
molecules and things like that and you
wanted to be able to learn some property
about such kind of systems then
potentially maybe you can use you can
shine light on it and capture the
photons maybe
one day store it in quantum memory and
then throw multiple copies of them and
do some entangled management on top um i
think this transaction part
where you have quantum sensor um
like shining lights and capturing the
slide coherently and storing it in
quantum memory i think that's still
quite challenging um i know that people
have been actively studying these tests
about this
in the field called transduction but
but still i think the transaction
fidelity at the moment is still pretty
low
i think it's also a problem even in
other kind of fields like in quantum
network now
in order to build quantum internet
people have also need this
important ingredient of transduction
where one can transduce from like
microwave signals to like
like more other kinds of flight signals
um even for that i think that
maybe ignacio ciroc can correct me or
provide some context but i heard it was
the fidelity was like 10 to the negative
four or five which is extremely low and
improving on that would be very
important for sort of
building on top of these
lineup works
yeah thanks thanks robert so we are
getting close to uh time here so
um
just um
just want to see if anybody has anything
else to say on the panel or you or um
maybe even the audience before we call
this to an end
i have a quick question um
for ela um
so so you mentioned sort of this
connection with the field of control
where you sort of if i understand
correctly you have an unknown dynamical
system
you not only want to learn the dynamics
so basically doing system identification
which is what the robert was doing but
you also want to
simultaneously control the state to be
let's say in a certain region
and you mentioned sort of you're
interested in the connection of this to
quantum computing right
for this connection i was wondering do
you have in mind more using quantum
computing to learn a classical learn and
control a classical dynamical system
or do you have in mind some ideas for
controlling uh a quantum system
do you have thoughts of using quantum
computing to control uh
a quantum system
thanks for the question andrea i mean
this was
i think my comments for the second part
of the talk which were more vague
and it just reminded
i guess um
the field of trying to learn
a system from observation
which is not only
doesn't only have the objective of
learning but also to reach a desired
state
and that is the field of learning in
dynamical systems so that is tackled by
that
mathematical technique
the reason i think that this particular
what i was afraid what i think can be
particularly interesting here
is the
um the fact that the
mathematics that you folks are using
and
namely
no norms of where the complex matrices
and so on
i think these are very interesting for
because if you know the literature
the system is for example stable a
linear dynamical system is stable
if it's something called the spectral
radius is less than one this is an
interesting
object it's not the eigenvalue of the
matrix it's not the singular value
it's something to do with
you take the meat the matrix of this
describing the system if it's a linear
system and take all its powers
and you look at the kind of the infinite
horizon and this is
bounded as a series it's an interesting
object
i have a feeling that
this
kind of interesting mathematics
can be even more you know compounded by
using
the stuff that you guys are doing them
the complex analysis techniques
it's more of a hunch i mean i don't have
i have not worked on that stuff at all
but i've seen this happen for example in
in the shadow tomography that stuff
scott showed this showed me some very
interesting
things that happened there that i didn't
expect so for example
scott's early result right you can learn
even though there are exponentially many
states you can need only probably a
number of measurements that's kind of
the really early results you can only
pull in number of measurements to learn
the whole thing various issues that
arise though that i didn't expect will
happen but
what happened because of the special
structure you have in cubits
and i just think it's very interesting
to classical control by itself has this
magical stuff happening
because of the spectral radius and once
this systems are stable and so on and
this could be a very nice
interaction
to look at but i don't i don't have
anything concrete more concrete than
that to say
if that makes sense
oh great um
okay so
thank you
thank you everybody so thanks robert for
a fantastic talk and
thanks to the panelists for a wonderful
discussion
so with that i think we
uh
i should
say this was the this was the last
colloquium for this year so um
happy holidays to everybody and see you
again in january
thank you
okay
thanks